yeah i'm gonna start though with this
titans news it looked like everything
was fine
it looked like they had finally reached
a point where they were not generating
positive tests they had gone multiple
days of negative tests they were ready
to go back to work today
in advance of their looming game on
sunday against the buffalo bills
until the news came early this morning
that the titans once again
have positive tests which means the plug
has been pulled
indefinitely once again on the titans
ability to return to work
throwing into doubt the question of
whether or not
the bills and the titans will play this
weekend and there won't be an easy fix
like there was last week because the
titans have already had their buy
the buy is gone if they can't play this
game monday night and oh by the way the
bills are scheduled to play next
thursday night so
probably won't be another monday night
double header this week
this is a game that would be part of
presumably week 18
unless they just scrapped the game or
unless
they declare a forfeit which has been
threatened by the league
but which no one really believes the
league would do because when you start
forfeiting games
you start not getting paid for games and
players start not getting paid
shireen still gets paid for today even
if we can't keep her signal up
consistently hello shireen welcome to
the program
i missed you i think i think sims was
over there playing video games or
something with my
my high speed internet i could hear you
i just you couldn't see me apparently
well we can't hear or see the tennessee
titans and
i was just talking now about how you
make up the bills titans game
if this stream of positives that was
interrupted for a couple of days
continues
there is no easy answer this time around
yeah they probably are going to have two
options you had
add a week to the end of the season
especially if we start to see more games
postponed
which i have a feeling we're going to
see let's hope not but but you do have a
feeling it's leaning that way that we're
going to have more postponements
as we move along here and the second
option obviously would be
you play however many games you play and
it goes to winning percentage and that's
what you end up with and maybe it's like
it the strike shortened season
when they just lump everybody together
and go hey the percentages of the top
however many teams make the playoffs but
we're not doing divisions and all that
sort of thing but yeah they're getting
into a
crunch here to try to make this thing
work
you're referring primarily 1982 back
when
you and i were both 17 years old and the
nfl played only nine games that year
because of a strike the thing though is
everyone played nine games
this is unprecedented at least in the
modern era i suspect that if we look at
the
record and factbook all the way back to
the early 20s there may have been years
where some teams played fewer games than
others
but since the merger at a minimum
she goes again she doesn't like what i'm
saying since the merger
at a minimum every team has played the
same number of games
and that's really the challenge here
because once the fans
start to process the idea that some
teams may play fewer than 16 games and
others are going to play 16 and maybe
someone play 14
that's just not going to sit well with
anyone so that's something that we need
to be concerned about i was on with
chris mad dog russo
last hour and he raised an interesting
point about
the options for extending the regular
season
and one of the concerns is if we start
adding weeks to the regular season you
could have
teams that have two three four weeks off
before they play their playoff game
especially the teams that earn a buy
there'll be two of them this year
they ordinarily have two weeks between
games they would have three if we had a
week 18 they would have
four if we had a week 19. he suggested
the possibility of taking week 17 as it
currently
is moving it to week 18
so that teams would have week 17 off
unless they have to make up a game
they'd play
week 18 and then the post season starts
the following week
eliminating that unexpected bye week
for the teams that don't need to make up
a game that's a possibility but
we may need two weeks of makeup games to
get this season in
and it's going to be a challenge we've
only got 40
what is it 64. 63 games played because
bills
and steelers wasn't played 63 games
played that means
193 to go is that right my math is
rarely right and in that case it may be
correct 193 games left to be played and
who knows how many of them
will ultimately be played this season
the titans are in trouble for multiple
reasons we had believed that the league
was going to place blame on the
tennessee titans for
the pandemic outbreak that they have
endured the argument is
from the league and this is something
multiple coaches are sensing
the league's position is if you follow
our protocols to the letter you'll be
fine
so if you're not fine you must not have
followed our protocols to the letter so
it's your fault
so we're going to look to place blame on
you and find
fault with you and punish you if you
have an outbreak
that results from not following our
protocols because if you follow our
protocols you won't have an outbreak so
ipso facto
you must not have followed our protocols
we're going to punish you the titans
already have that working against them
now this news that seems to have been
admitted by guard roger saffold the
titans got together
last week and had a tom brady style
practice
at a local high school that's going to
make it even worse
and i've been told that the talking
league circles and there's the
photographs
of the workouts involving men much older
and larger than what you typically see
on a high school field
i've been told that the
league could end up imposing historic
punishment
on the titans for this because this is
defiance this isn't
well it's better to ask for forgiveness
than it is to ask for permission so
we're going to interpret a rule
incorrectly and then you get whacked and
you find out maybe it would have been
better to ask for permission
this is thou shalt not do it
and immediately turning around and doing
it
that's why the titans are facing that
double whammy and the possibility
that they are going to get hit in a way
that no team
has ever been hit before by the national
football league that all is still
pending
and the main thing is they got 11
players who have now tested positive
over the past two weeks
corey davis is the latest receiver who
was a top 10 draft pick by the titans
and still an important member of the
offense although maybe not as good as he
was supposed to be you still need to
have these guys
they're going to be short-handed if they
play this weekend and again i don't know
that they can play
and if they can't play i don't know when
they're going to play the bill's titans
game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports